foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday October 28th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
all this week we've been bringing you
some of the most interesting and
thought-provoking discussions from the
Wall Street journal's Tech live
conference
to wrap up the week we recorded a
special episode in front of a live
audience outside in Laguna Beach
California
I sat down with wsj tech reporter Tim
Higgins to discuss a key theme from the
conference why self-driving technology
hasn't lived up to the hype at least not
as quickly as promised case in point
Intel spun out its self-driving car unit
mobilei this week valuing it at 17
billion dollars that is more than it
paid for the company but far less than
the 50 billion Intel had hoped for
so why have mobileye and others in the
autonomous driving space struggled here
are highlights from that conversation
with Tim Tim I want to start with Intel
Pat gelsinger was here at Tech live on
Monday and he was asked about the
company's plans to spin out mobileye
Intel brought mobilei to an IPO at a
significantly lower valuation than was
expected what went wrong
yeah I mean this is kind of maybe a
canary in the coal mine if you will
about the state of autonomous vehicle
technology out there mobile I uh it
produces the kind of the brains for
driver assist programs out there for
vehicles but also is working on fully
self-driving technology and they were
hoping to IPO at a valuation of 50
billion and now it's dramatically less
hey you've got an issue that the market
for IPOs is just it's a horrible time to
be out there but there's also concern
among investors that I have talked to
just about kind of the state of
autonomous vehicle technology is this
actually going to happen in the near
term and where does mobileye play in
that you know this is something this
kind of Technology not just mobileye but
this the state of driverless cars we
have been talking about it for more than
a decade and it's always kind of been
something that was near term it was just
on the horizon but it's proven time and
time again to be harder than everybody
initially anticipated and I think some
people's patience is waning for it okay
then where does the state of driverless
technology stand at the moment well it's
not Knight Rider you know the the the
famous uh self-driving car crime fighter
sure it's more nuanced and more limited
you can take a fully self-driving car in
Phoenix right now using waymo which is
uh Google's self-driving uh subsidiary
but you know it's this is limited uh you
can't go everywhere out there and
they're slowly rolling out this service
they're going to San Francisco and they
just announced Los Angeles and what
we've found and what they have found is
that there's a huge back-end component
to this technology you gotta you gotta
charge the vehicle you got to put
windshield wiper fluid you got to clean
it out if somebody leaves their purse or
you know they vomit in it or whatever
you got this huge infrastructure uh back
there which
I tend to call that vomit problem
because you think that the idea of when
this technology was first talked about
years ago was these role this is all
going to be automated and robots are
going to be taking over and it was just
going to be so easy you could just
deploy these things well it actually
requires an army of people behind the
scenes to keep the logistics going and
that's one of the big surprises I think
that the industry has dealt with in
recent years is trying to figure out
that complexity you spoke with the waymo
co-ceo uh here at Tech live on Monday we
actually have a clip of what she said in
reaction to what it is to get these cars
on the road this is really about being
patient in the learning but being very
precise in our execution of what makes
this a delightful service
so a delightful service do we have an
idea of when they're going to be able to
turn this into a more accessible
delightful service it's a city by City
kind of problem for them I mean think
about me as a driver you can plot me
down in Phoenix or I can go to San
Francisco or Los Angeles and I can get
off the plane and just start driving but
for them their driver which is how they
call their their service has to be tuned
for all those markets it has to be
trained the infrastructure has to be
built around it and it's taking time to
do that so it's clear that getting
faster at it but it's also it's more
than an engineering problem we talked
about logistics but there's a political
issue in Phoenix they were able to
easily roll out or they they rolled it
out but in California there's a level of
bureaucracies involved that they have to
have permissions from various places and
that takes time you know that's that's
such a good point and Pat gelsinger who
was also here at Tech live he spoke
about that a little bit uh when he
talked about ipoing mobile eye I think
we have a clip from him on regulation as
well well many other cities and
countries around the world are much more
advanced than the regulatory policies
enabling autonomous vehicles you know to
emerge more rapidly and clearly you know
to me you know not only do we need
things like chips and science act to
move things forward but we also need
regulatory policies to enable
Technologies to come forward so Tim does
that gel with what you've been hearing
from other autonomous driving companies
you know it's interesting for years
writing about this there's always been
this belief that self-driving technology
will have an easier time deploying in
China just because the government could
turn it on if they wanted to it's not
necessarily the case for U.S companies
given that these are essentially mobile
map making machines and there's concerns
about National Security there so there's
ego Market to Market there's different
complexities and there's different
logistical hurdles if you will here in
the states
the challenge has been traditionally the
federal government oversees the car and
the states oversee the driver and so the
question becomes when the car is the
driver who's who's in charge there a
company like waymo would like it to be
at a federal level so you could have one
rule to rule at all here in the states
uh where you know we're still kind of in
early days of local governments uh
deciding how they want to weigh in
environment and
then expected mean for investors in this
space it's all kind of that level of
complexity and risk that just increases
we saw in 2018 the first death of a
person involved was hit by a test
driving self-driving car uh in Phoenix
area by Uber at the time and that really
put the industry back it all of a sudden
shook a lot of people is that you know
this if it wasn't already clear we are
dealing with uh life and death
technology and that gives people some
pause you know how do you know if the
system works how do you know if the car
that's being put on the road is safe Tim
Higgins wsj reporter thank you so much
for joining us thank you
[Applause]
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week our producer is Julie Chang
our supervising producer is Chris
sinsley and I'm your host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
[Music]